i've for
for uh
five six years at mit
really focused on this
human side of driving question and one
of the big concerns is
the uh
micro sleeps drowsiness these kinds of
ideas and one of the open questions was
is it possible through computer vision
to detect or any kind of sensors
the nice thing about computer vision is
you don't have to have direct contact to
the person
is it possible to detect
increases in drowsiness is it possible
to detect these kind of micro sleeps or
actually just sleep in general
among other things a distraction these
are all words that have so many meanings
there's so many debates like like
attention is a whole another one just
because you're looking something doesn't
mean
you're loading in the information just
because you're looking away doesn't mean
your peripheral vision can't pick up the
important information there's so many
complicated vision science things there
um so i i wonder if you could say
something to
uh you know they say the eyes or the
windows to the soul do you think um
the eyes can reveal
something about uh
sleepiness
uh through uh through computer vision
through
just looking at the video of the face
and andrew huberman and i your friend
i've talked about this so i would love
to work on this uh together so you
should do it's a fascinating problem but
drowsiness is a tricky one so there's
what kind of information
there's uh blinking and there's eye
movement
and those are the ones that can be
picked uh up with computer vision do you
think those are signals that could be
used to say something about
where we are in this continuum yeah i do
and i think there are a number of other
features too i think um you know
aperture of eye so in other words
partial closures foreclosures
duration of those closures duration of
those partial closures of the eyelid
um
i think there may be some information in
the pupil as well because as we're
transitioning between those states chain
there are changes in what's called the
automatic nervous system or
technically it's called the autonomic
nervous system part of which will
control your
pupillary size so i actually think that
there is probably a wealth of
information when you combine that
probably with
aspects of steering angle steering
maneuver
and if you can sense the pressure
on the pedals as well
my guess is that there is some
combinatorial feature that creates a
phenotype
of
you are starting to fall asleep and as
the autonomous controls develop
the
it's time for them to kick in some
manufacturers auto manufacturers sort of
have something
better version maybe an alpha version of
of this already starting to come online
where they have a little camera in the
wheel that i think tries to look at some
features almost everybody doing this and
it's very alpha
so
uh you know the thing that you currently
have some people have that in their car
there's a coffee cup or something that
comes up that you might be sleepy the
the primary signal that they're
comfortable using is the steering wheel
reversals so so basically using your
interaction with the steering wheel and
how much you're interacting with it as a
sign of sleepiness so if you have to
constantly correct the car yeah and
that's a sign of like you starting to
drift into microsleep i think that's a
very very crude signal it's probably a
powerful one there's a whole other
component to this which is
it seems like it's so driver and subject
dependent
um
the how our behavior changes as we
get sleepy and drowsy seems to be
different in complicated fascinating
ways where you can't just use one signal
it's kind of like what you're saying
there has to be
a lot of different signals that you
should then be able to combine the hope
is there's uh the searches for like
universal signals that are pretty damn
good for like 90 of people
but i don't think we need to take
necessarily quite that approach i think
what we could do
in some clever fashion is
using the individual so what you and i
are perhaps suggesting here is that
there is
an array of features that we know
provide information that is sensitive to
whether or not you're falling asleep at
the wheel
some of those let's say that there are
10 of them you know for me seven of them
are the cardinal features
for you however you know six of them and
they're not all the same sort of
overlapping are those for you
i think what we need is algorithms that
can firstly understand when you are well
slept so let's say that people have
sleep trackers at night and then your
car integrates that information that'd
be amazing understands when you are well
slept yeah and then you've got the data
of the individual behavior unique to
that individual snowflake like
when they are well slept this is the
signature of well-rested driving
then you can look at deviations from
that and pattern match it with the sleep
history of that individual and then i
don't need to find
the sort of you know the one size fits
all approach for 99 of the people i can
create a very bespoke tailor-like set of
features the savile row suit of
sleepiness features you know that would
be my if you want to ask me about
moonshots and crazy ideas that's where i
go but to start with i think your
approach is a great one let's find
something that covers 99 of the people
because the worrying thing about
microsleeps of course unlike you know
drugs or alcohol which you know
certainly is a terrible thing to be
behind the wheel
with those often you
you react too late
and that's the reason you get into an
accident
when you fall asleep behind the wheel
you don't react at all the you know at
that point there is a two-ton missile
driving down the street and no one's in
control that's why those accidents can
often be more dangerous
yeah and
the fascinating thing is in the case of
semi-autonomous vehicles like tesla
autopilot this is where
i've had disagreements with mr elon musk
is uh
and uh the human factors community
which is this community that one of the
big things they study
is human supervision over automation
so you have like pilots
you know supervising an airplane that's
mostly flying autonomously the question
is
when we're actually doing the driving
how do micro sleeps or general how does
drowsiness progress and how does it
affect our driving that question becomes
more fascinating more complicated
when your task is not driving but
supervising the driving so your task is
to take over when stuff goes wrong and
that
is complicated but
the basic conclusions from many decades
is that humans are really crappy at
supervising
because they get
they get drowsy and lose vigilance much
much faster
the really surprising thing with tesla
autopilot it was surprising to me it's
surprising to uh the human factors
community and in fact they still argue
with me about it is uh it seems that
humans
in tesla's with autopilot
and other similar systems are not
becoming less vigilant
at least
the with the studies we've done so
there's something about the urgency of
driving i can't i'm not sure the why but
there's something about the risk i think
the fact that he might die
is still keeping people awake the
question is as tesla autopilot or
similar systems get better and better
and better
how does that affect increasing
drowsiness and that's when you need to
have that's what the big disagreement
was you need to have driver sensing
meaning driver facing camera
that tracks some kind of information
about the face that can tell you
uh drowsiness so you can tell the car if
you're drowsy so that the car can be
like you should be
probably driving or pull to the side
right or i need to do some of the heavy
lifting here yeah um so there needs to
be that dance of inter interaction
relief
of a human and machine
but currently it's mostly uh steering
wheel based so
you know this this idea that your hands
should be on the on the steering wheel
that's
a sign that you're paying attention
is um isn't outdated and a very crude
metric i agree
yeah i think they're off far more
sophisticated ways that we can solve
that problem
if we invest
you